is mocking Christianity what do you
think of that listen just proves why
Christians are the greatest wait wait
what oh you want them on your team no
we're just we're just the greatest guys
we're just the greatest why why are we
the greatest because we let people do
their jokes we let people do their
little music
videos gross oh you're calling him a
joke now that's what you're doing yeah
he's a joke wow but we let them do the
jokes and we don't go blow them up we
don't get all crazy like everybody can
have their free them to do whatever they
want and then we let the Creator decide
what should happen to them at the end of
the day what do you think happen to him
say again what do you think should
happen to little nox whatever daddy
wants that happen happen
know I wish him well you know I mean I
hope he finds the Lord again he
apologized for what it's worth yeah he
rep he repented apologized he repented
he repented also also Christians and God
knows that he's just using Christianity
you know to get views it's the oldest
trick of the book for music arti artist
I mean rockers did it back in the day
you mean like being a Preacher what's
that what's that I mean just using
Christianity just for monetary gain and
things of that nature oh are you saying
that there are people that do that I
think there's a lot of people that do
that but I don't
know yeah here with chran that is
disgusting does it happen other face
there like uh like gospel like Hindu
there's that kind of thing where like we
can fix your life give us money yeah
that definitely and they get paid off it
the wealth gospel exists yeah yeah yeah
well maybe not like we can heal you and
all that stuff if that's what you call
Wealth gospel like I accumulate wealth
off of promising you things yeah no that
also is there but I think the wealth
gospel is specifically if you want to be
rich believe in these things I'm sure
that exists I see the like I'll heal you
and fix the problems in your life and
yeah all that stuff and do they get like
Millions off it I don't know if they get
millions but they get they get decent
money yeah religion does make money yeah
the Christian grifters are pretty good
at making the most money why do you
think that is and just be honest
why do you think that
is the dumb
because that crazy is that crazy
no no Muslims are the dumbest followers
right wow I'm not going to say that I
know that one was wor they are the
dumbest I'm not they're also the
scariest so I'm not going to say nothing
no but they're the dumbest like if a
literal IQ they're by far the dumbest
you're crazy why because they go blow
themselves up
no Christian can do that church is too
fire Sunday he going to miss out he need
that wafer you know yeah but then yall
have the followers that just get popped
on the head and all of a sudden they
think they're healed and all that [__]
like they convince people that come on
that's pretty stupid you can't say it
doesn't work Ben Carson you can't say
that what they're doing isn't equally as
effective as what Ben Carson did you
can't say it all right but then there's
other ones that just go H and they think
that the holy spirit is talking to you
ever been to a yoga class
yes yeah get it out get get it out they
tell you they say wooa whatever that is
just get it out the system you feel
relaxed after you get it out the Church
of Martino there we go you got the wooa
what I'm trying to say is sometimes you
just need to get it out if you're going
to get it out in tongues you get it out
in tongues sometimes you just need to
get it out regular some of that speaking
in tongue [__] is crazy is really crazy
and y'all people believe I've seen
people do that I mean it's mainly the
black Christians that I see do hey hey
hey hey we just talk about Christians
here right just overall we're not going
div them up we're not going to divide
them up yeah no when I was in high
school we went to a Bible study and
people started speaking in tongues I was
like I like it it wasn't Catholic it was
like even like a Pentecostal church or
whatever so when Jamaicans do it it's
cool a little bit they go wild a but
what about like the skib b b wo that's
what they're doing but that's fire when
black people do it yeah just a what
about when James Brown does it it's the
greatest song ever but when you do it
for Christ then all of a sudden oh it's
corny these people are so weird you're a
hater you're going to hell you're on the
fence you
believe I know you believe thanks I
know I'm just trying to say when James
Brown does it it's fire when the
Christians do it all of a sudden it's
weird that is Boulder DH why haven't
call poy [__] that is poppy [__] as well
that's also a fire word Tong yet say
again why haven't you spoken in Tong I
speak in tongues literally half the
podcast you know what I mean like we
make fun of Al when he does it too but
we shouldn't Al's out here speaking in
tongues as well man of God Biden is the
closest to God he speaks the T every
speech if Biden would just accept his
Christianity I think he might win thise
absolutely if he was just out
there and he just went whoa that's all
he need to do at the end of every he's
winning guaranteed see you later Trump
adios do you do you accept his apology
he said he didn't know what he was doing
he said he it's all I mean it's just
like the same he was like I didn't I
wasn't trying to troll I was just having
fun or something like that I didn't mean
to offend anybody no you know it's views
you know the Christians are going to get
all [__] upset about it it was
absolutely trolling and then he said
something like um yeah I read an article
about his apology say something like uh
I'm not the first rapper to dress like
Jesus and I won't be the last and it's
like yeah but you are the first rapper
to dress like Jesus on the crucifix with
[__] cheer litter boots I mean you're
the first gay Jesus for sure and not
just cuz you're gay but you made him gay
he calls it art yeah that's cool but
don't act like this is something people
have done before and you weren't you
were trolling one of the great things
about the Jud Christian values of the
United States of America is you can do
something like this and you won't get
thrown off a
building also there's a movie that is
awesome about how State he goes to say
again depends on what state he goes to
that's fair but I don't think they can
legally throw him off buildings in any
state in the United States of amerx tour
probably like eight states and that's it
that's true and there might be people
that get very upset about it but
technically speaking it is not legal for
them to go to the top floor of the
highest building and toss his gas off it
it's not legal where there are countries
where they specifically build buildings
for this
reason specifically I mean if you look
at no no you look at those like uh
there's these like uh these map images
of what Dubai was like 50 years ago to
what it's like now yeah and I don't know
if the gays got good at flying or
something but they kept making the
buildings taller and taller and taller
slingshot they put a slingshot on this
they have toifa they have to the Burge
Khalifa is I think the tallest building
in the world yes and
um the inaugural toss when that happens
is going to be unbelievable it is going
to be so amazing I mean do they just
take Mia Khalifa and throw her right off
actually be a fire way to go out I'm
just the elevator ride you'd be like
this is high as [__] but I'm going to
enjoy until
the it is crazy I was talking to this
gay dude he's like yeah I don't travel
to places where it's illegal to be gay
and it never crossed my mind it makes
complete sense it never crossed my mind
that like there's part of the world just
cut off from you if you're a gay dude
traveling yeah he was like yeah I
wouldn't go to Jamaica probably they
save all that money yeah probably travel
but just blew my mind I was like yo this
guy goes his whole life being like I
can't go there it's illegal to exist but
why would they know you're gay come well
then you know they got supreme gar over
there too I guess they do I guess like
if you really want to go to a place I
wouldn't let your sexual proclivities
stop you from doing that yeah you got
detained and they looked at your phone
saw a lot of dicks
say I have friends with a great sense of
humor like you don't prayed me when they
F my ass for six
years I'm just saying like if you really
want to go some place is the only reason
that you're traveling so you can get
butt [__] if you really want to go
someplace and indulge in that culture
you're curious about that culture
whether you have sex with men or not is
such a small part of your life and your
existence in that part of your travels
like when I go travel I'm not having sex
can I tell you what if they can't turn
off the Sass that's well can I just say
one thing bro as a man who's sitting
like this right now let me tell you it
can be turned on and turned off okay I I
you can turn it off this is one of the
more impressive things I've ever seen
you do what's that is to take countries
or it's legal to be gay and be like what
kind of are you for not visiting that
country low key facts like if you're gay
and you want to go see is it legal to be
gay in China probably right let's find
out I mean what the difference between
[__] a Chinese man and woman at this
is where you go too
far cross L actual you go too far like
this what is the actual physical
difference oh my God okay this is no no
but for example let's say you really
want to go to the Middle East right you
really want to go out there okay go you
can't not [__] a dude for a weekend you
probably feel feelings that they don't
like you they gay they're not even
thinking about you yeah but they don't
like gay people and you're a gay person
so you're like f if you're walking
around in a burka like a [__] idiot
it's obviously going to be a red flag
that you're a gay but if you you know
dress like everybody else you're going
to be good to
go like I I'm just there's no way
anybody would know you're gay if you're
not but [__] a dude or trying to [__]
a dude and if you really want to go to a
place just eliminate the sex part of
your vacation it's very easy it's called
marriage we do it every single time like
I am I wrong for thinking this yeah it
sucks that they don't like you okay we
got that out of the way do you want to
go or not yeah but once what they're the
super flam boyant on and also again I
think you can't the super duper are we
still doing that are we still doing the
super FL Bo you see the little nasx
video but we can't still be doing that
in this what is it 2024 we still doing
that yeah man that's bro I'm sorry
that's like those are like the lugs
boots of g at this point like who else
is going to fix your closet and [__]
like you need them I'm not saying that
they don't have impeccable style and are
absolutely hilarious and you would never
want to be in the other other end of a
rose from them of course that being said
if they are interested in going to
Iran hide it for [__] four days I
think they're probably not that
interested because they're resentful
that they hate gay people and they're a
gay person you understand what I'm
saying so that makes them be like you
know what [__] y'all too I don't I'm
American I go to every country we bomb
happily how can they not I went to Tokyo
oh this thing's still here they don't
hate America though they got more of a
reason
to they got way more of a reason to than
some gay guy who's going to a place
where it's illegal to be gay but you
just got to not suck [__] for a week
they forgive would you go to China hell
yeah oh would you go to Afghanistan hell
yeah really North Korea hell
no I got South it's can't be that
different yeah realistically it canot
that wildly different oh but the culture
in the north I'm not that interested but
in terms of like the people if you got I
mean you can say that about any of those
countries true would you do a tour for
like a guided like you would be safe you
just do one dayri for six hours go I'm
terrified dude never ever no I've seen
people's tours it looks boring it's it's
it's like there's nothing like Sweden
doesn't have enough to offer that I need
to go back there like it's not worth
putting white face on just to go back to
Sweden I I hear that so maybe for them
they feel it's just not worth it but you
know the repercussions they don't know
the repercussions yet how many people
have been arrested for being gay in
these other countries like give me the
number like where does the fear then
come from if I'm saying if you are truly
interested in travel if you're truly for
example if you're truly interested in
travel and you're going to a country
that is incredibly religious and you do
not adhere to that religion you're going
to put your religion in the tuck when
you go there yeah like your Hinduism
your Christianity your whatever it is
because you know that that might put you
in danger for example if you're going to
a place where if you're a woman and you
got to cover up because the religion
asks you to cover up you go cover up
right that's not how you actually dress
that's not how you actually are that's
not how you actually exist but you cover
up you don't touch men because you're
not supposed to do it you respect
whatever the culture is there if you're
interested in seeing the culture I don't
think being gay gay being
illegal is enough of a reason to not go
to a place unless you have to have a
[__] in your throat every 24 hours if
you can't take a 72h hour sabatical from
getting your your [__] have you ever met
a gay person before man you're making a
good point they can't go a day they Go's
half gay would she not go to a place
because really yeah I'm surprised you
didn't know the answer to that really I
don't believe that's true I believe that
she would go to
Jamaica I don't think they have a
problem with the wom
Gaye it's only fish boys True H fair
enough yeah I like their
system PR pick up yo last week I end up
being right because I picked two this no
no no it's Akash is locks Akash locks I
got I believe Josh Allen getting more
yards they have him at like 270 right
now Josh Allen more and then I had who
did I have getting Jordan Love Les I
don't think he's going to repeat the
same performance Jordan love less these
are my aash really yeah is this because
the the 49ers are just an actual good
defense got it and I do I do feel like
football is so up and down that after he
had like him and it was the greatest
performance ever for a rookie
quarterback and then they brought him
back into the game and he threw one in
completion and so it became tied for the
great ever but it it was unbelievable
he's perfect wow and I just don't think
he can repeat that got it so so what
you're saying is sometimes in football
you're not riding the high yeah it sound
like I was setting them up miles I
wasn't but like meaning like you're not
riding the high you are there's a come
down from the high like the high almost
satisfies your competitive instinct or
whatever this is kind of what I feel I
do think momentum is a real thing
throughout the season but sometimes you
just hit such an apex that there's
really only one place to go and order
for him to beat the 49ers he needs to
play at that level yeah and they're just
their defense is so [__] good their
pass rush is so [__] good don't see
it okay well that's the priz pi priz
picks.com make sure you use the promo
Cod Schultz SZ get them picks in get
that money because you know what they're
going to do they're going to match that
initial deposit bonus uh up to $100 $100
you put in aund you get a free hun to go
gamble you got the Aros sing locks yep
okay simple as that